para analizar esta Victoria del Barça
está con nosotros Sara Castro directora
de deportes de Caracol radio también del
día del diario as Colombia Sara Muchas
gracias por estar en deportes domingo
como siempre un gusto estar con ustedes
Sara comenzamos preguntándote esta ha
sido la pausa más larga de títulos en
los últimos 20 años para el Barcelona
Qué cambió con la llegada de Xavi para
que finalmente se diera esta celebración
es el primer título desde 2019 que es lo
mismo que decir el primer título sin
Lionel Messi qué fue lo que buscó el
Barça trayendo a Xavi lo primero
identidad incidente una crisis no sólo
da resultados institucional Xavi
representaba lo mejor del Barça
representaba sus convicciones
futbolísticas y sobre todo un pasado al
que querían aferrarse y yo creo que Xavi
tuvo la inteligencia de ir adaptando un
poco esa idea esa idea de ese Barça
ganador a través de los días Entonces si
ustedes me preguntan qué es lo que
cambió en el equipo yo creo que fue un
más pragmático un equipo más práctico un
equipo con hambre con ambición que es lo
más parecido a la convicción y sobre
todo que fue encontrando altos niveles
en sus futbolistas lewandowski por
ejemplo en la primera vuelta de la liga
fue muy relevante es un jugador con 20
goles también la aparición de Araujo de
jugadores como balde
de ese mediocampo en donde esos cuatro
volantes le dieron por fin el equilibrio
y sobre todo la gestación del juego que
necesitaba el Barcelona con jugadores
como Pedri es decir estamos hablando de
un Barça que a pesar de las dificultades
y sin tener una competencia
internacional que hay que tenerlo sin
estar compitiendo en Europa en Champions
logró capitalizar eso para por fin
empezar un proyecto futbolístico que sin
duda Esperemos que la próxima temporada
de frutos también a nivel europeo